[Music]
hello my name is eleoni gomez alves i am
a biologist and i work for the max
planck institute for biogeochemistry
indiana germany i am florian whitman i
am professor at the khalsa institute of
technology
and i'm head of the department of
wetland ecology
and working for years in the ato project
[Music]
the amazon tao tower observatory atto is
a project from a collaboration between
brazil and germany and it has an
experimental site in the center of
amazon and this site we have a tao tower
a very tall tower of 325 meters and two
other towers of 80 meters height from
which we measured the air in the same
experimental site we also do research
with soils and vegetation
the main purpose of ato is to collect
information that tells us on
meteorological chemical and biological
processes that represent the forest the
atmosphere and how they talk to each
other the climate system is influenced
by this conversation between the forest
and the atmosphere and we at atom wanted
to disclose this conversation in order
to better understand natural processes
and also to be able to make more
accurate climate predictions
this started between the max planck
society specifically the max planck
institute for chemistry and minds
together with the national institute for
amazonian research empire in manaus
and
well we followed the idea and
found a place for the tower a good place
remote place
but not too remote
and
built it planned it built it during
several years
well the main question is how the
biosphere interacts with
the by the atmosphere
so
for instance which kinds of
gases
air results whatever
come out of the forest and how
increasingly changing atmospheres
interact
or influence forest growth and
the ecology and the functioning
of the forest so how this interchange
between forest and the atmosphere is
working
my research is on the volatile oregon
compounds emitted by plants
these compounds are known as the forest
scent
for you to have an idea of what i mean
with forest scent
try to remember when you did smell a
leaf of mint
i'm quite sure that you can recognize
this scent every time that you are
around mint
similarly the forest also has scents
which are blends of thousands and
thousands of compounds and there are
several reasons
why plants release these compounds
they can do so to communicate with other
plants what we call chemical
communication
or to repel
a predator for example some gases are
toxic to insects and once they are
released by a plant they can prevent an
insect attack to the plant
and when it's super hot or dry plants
can also release some of these gases to
survive
and after being released by plants these
gases get involved into chemical
reactions in the air that can transform
them into particles what we call
aerosols
this is a very important process in the
climate system because aerosols are
essential
for cloud formation when clouds are
being formed
it's necessary to have two things the
surface and the water vapor to condense
on the surface
and then start the process in which
clouds grow
aerosols are the surface
uh where the
water vapor condense on so they work as
a seed for cloud formation
my focus is to understand what triggers
plants to produce and release this sense
but as i am part of an interdisciplinary
team the results of my research can help
the atmospheric scientists to understand
the follow-up processes that these
scents take part in the atmosphere as
the formation of particles and then
cloud formation
what we have discovered is that this
blend of compounds
change
change substantially
over the seasons in central amazon we
basically have two seasons the rainy
season and the dry season and as i said
some of these compounds can protect
plants against heat
and drought
and during the dry season because
the the temperature
is higher and the air is drier we have
more emission of some compounds and this
is interesting because some of some
studies have predicted that in the
future we will have longer and more
intense dry seasons or droughts so this
can give us an indication that plants
probably will emit more of these
compounds to survive in these harsher
environments
my part
our part is more towards understanding
the ecology and eco-physiology of trees
so we are not directly involved in
atmospheric measurements but we are
involved in the functioning of trees for
instance
during
the season from where trees
take their water
if this is different between the
different rainforest ecosystems because
we have flooded forests we have dry
forests we have
tall rainforest and these forests are
quite different in species composition
and biodiversity
and functioning and our interest is
mainly focusing on how
these trees are able to track their
water sources
and if they are stressed out for
instance during dry conditions if there
are ecosystems that are more stressed
out than others
and also tree species that are more
stressed out during drought for instance
or during
inundations
[Music]
there are
hundreds of scientists involved in the
research there are the atmospheric
chemists
there are biologists there are
[Music]
people
from all over the globe from different
european countries from brazil
but also from the us
so
many many scientists involved in
different research questions going from
soils up to the atmosphere
the so-called boundary layer where we
have still the interchange between local
rainforest and the atmosphere closer to
the to the canopy
up to the height of 300 meters so there
are very different
scientific questions and scientists
involved
studying remote sensing
applying remote sensing applying
biological measurements
climate measurements and so on
and the logistics staff
which includes the drivers of cars and
boats
the staff that works in the maintenance
of the experimental side for example the
tower workers the cook
the locals from the communities around
ato these are people that help us in the
field with data collection
for example a tree climber from the
community works with me because he
collects the leaves from the tree top
that i use for my measurements
and also these locals help us because
they teach us many things about the
forest like species of plants and
animals
and also we have a lot of researchers
and students from local institutions
working at the experimental site
[Music]
auto is the biggest project in the
amazon forest that investigates the
interaction between forest and that in
the atmosphere that conversation that i
mentioned before
the long-term monitoring of gases like
co2 water vapor and the blend of plant
sands can give information that allows
us to see trends in the climate
for example uh we can investigate if the
forest is being a zinc or a source of
co2 the amazon forest has been
considered an important continental
carbon storage for the planet and in
fact the carbon stored in the amazon
forest represents 10 years of the
current global carbon emission and also
some past studies have suggested that
the forest is a sink of co2
from the atmosphere
this co2 sync role is a critical factor
in preventing faster rates of climate
change however
a recent study indicated that some
regions of the amazon forest are
becoming a source of co2 and these
together with other effects of climate
change like the
increase in temperature and more intense
and longer droughts can contribute to
the acceleration of climate change so
imagine if all of the carbon stored in
the amazon forest goes to the atmosphere
that would be really bad
so as the atop tower can measure gases
that come from very very far away as far
as 1 000 kilometer from the tower to the
east we can have information from a huge
area in the amazon and this can help us
to understand the interaction between
the amazon forest and the climate now
and in the future
first of course is the special situation
where we measure mostly pristine forests
with little influence of human impact
at a very special place in the middle of
the rainforest this is very unique on
the one hand and on the other hand
it brings together
joins all different kinds of researches
and institutions which of course work
interdisciplinary
at the international level and this of
course
important to respond broader questions
on on how for instance
rainforests may react to climate changes
how resilient these three species are
and how
resistant the entire ecosystem tropical
rainforest especially in the amazon
is
against the change actual
global climate change
[Music]
um you know that the rainforest is
important for
the entire human population not only for
the brazilians or for the europeans
it is
it is a very important source of carbon
and it is also a very important stock of
carbon and biomass and
of course
this
cooperation between germany and brazil
specifically the max planck society and
the brazilian institutions involved is
because we have long lasting
research programs
bilateral
programmes that last for more than
almost 50 years
so we have uh intense
interchange
of national interests here in
environmental research
which are the basis actually for the
success of that recent auto project
[Music]